white supremacy is terrorism everything
is white supremacy according to the left
by the transit of property everything
you don't like is terrorism
again he needs a crisis in order to
manufacture all the things that he wants
to do
so joe biden really did backload a lot
of the wildest stuff in the speech so
all of the spending we're gonna give you
free daycare we're gonna give you three
three and four year old head start
programs and free community college and
free this and free that
and a free blueberry for every person
and two belly buttons right we're gonna
we're gonna do
everything you could possibly that was
actually not the part of the speech the
wild part of the speech is when he
started talking about race
and guns and immigration this is where
it got
real weird real fast okay so he started
talking about how america's deeply
racist he starts off the speech with
america's great
uh it's a it's a great amazing filled
with amazing middle class
better back badugu and and also
but you're racist so here was joe biden
saying that you're racist
my fellow americans look we have to come
together
to heal the soul of this nation we've
all seen the name and justice on the
neck of black americans
now is our opportunity to make some real
progress
the vast majority of men and women
wearing a uniform and a badge serve
our communities and they serve them
honorably
my fellow americans we have to come
together
to rebuild trust between law enforcement
and the people they serve
to root out systemic racism in our
criminal justices okay stop it there we
don't need the rest of this okay so
there
there are a few things that are worthy
of note here one when he says we've seen
the knee of injustice on the neck of
black america
this again goes back to something i've
been saying for the last couple weeks
derek chauvin
was convicted of murder and manslaughter
but he was convicted of something of
which he was not even accused
being a racist and america was convicted
on the basis of that
of being racist systemically racist and
joe biden just continues to lie about
that that's why he says things like the
knee of injustice on the neck of black
america because derek chovan
is a stand-in for the racist bigoted
vicious american system
also cops are all wonderful but they're
systemic bigots right this is this is
just bizarre
stupid crap and joe biden pushes it
because again he needs a crisis
in order to manufacture all the things
that he wants to do
another crisis that allows him to
manufacture this sort of stuff he says
that
gun violence is an epidemic in america
an epidemic
again we just had an epidemic i'm pretty
sure it's not
like a shooting in chicago doesn't make
me pick up my gun and go shoot somebody
that's that's just ridiculous here he
was
doing this routine he says gun violence
is an epidemic in america and then
he starts talking about like deer in
kevlar vests
or or something this is where he starts
just rambling into
into weird territory have you ever seen
a deer or a kevlar vest i saw it one
time
a wolf and wolf wore a
cashmere sweater and it was weird give
me a hug
i pet him like corn pop's leg and
you don't need a gun there's joe biden
there's no possible justification for
having a hundred rounds
and a weapon
what do you think deer wearing kevlar
vests
um number one if
deer don't wear kevlar rust but
sometimes bad guys do too
does he really think that getting rid of
100 round
clips is going to somehow or 100 round
magazines is somehow going to lower gun
violence
when was the last time you saw somebody
committed shooting only
with that weapon like seriously how many
how many homicides in america are caused
by 100 round magazines and beyond which
forget the magazines you're just going
to have people walking around with
bandoliers right you'll be like an old
western
whatever this is all ridiculous then he
suggested that white supremacy is
terrorism now this was a departure okay
some of this stuff was ad-libbed and
when joe biden
ad libs you're in wild territory so joe
biden on script is bad enough joe biden
ad libbing
he's out in space somewhere so he was
talking about the intelligence community
and how white supremacist
terrorism is a threat in the united
states which is true there are white
supremacist terrorists and they do do
violence
we have seen that but he didn't say
white supremacist terrorism he went off
script and he said something else
entirely
something that actually is quite
dangerous okay here's here's what joe
biden said with regard to
terrorism and we won't ignore what our
intelligence agencies have
determined to be the most lethal
terrorist threat to the homeland today
white supremacy is terrorism we're not
going to ignore that either he didn't
say white supremacist
terrorism we can stop it there okay when
he says white supr
it should have been white supremacist
terrorism that's an actual label when he
says white supremacy is terrorism
right there that means something very
different because just think of all the
headlines that you've seen
in the past few months everything is
white supremacy according to the left
everything they don't like is white
supremacy
and educational inequality is white
supremacy systemic policing
is white supremacy hand sanitizer is
white supremacy
everything is white so if white
supremacy is terrorism and you're going
to use the power of the federal
government to crack down
on white supremacy then by the transit
of property everything you don't like is
terrorism
this is why you shouldn't let joe biden
off the chain to ad-lib because you end
up
in weird situations okay then he talked
about immigration reform
and this this honestly was one of the
best parts of the speech because he
talked about how politicians have failed
to do immigration reform
well there are tens of thousands of
children being held in being held
in in cages on the border and then he's
like you know my solution to that is he
said this last night his solution to
that
was to pass legislation to make it easy
for the dreamers to stay
create a pathway to citizenship for farm
workers and
put permanent protections on immigrants
for temporary protected status
so in other words we have a crisis on
the border with people washing into the
border by the tens of thousands
and the only solutions he mentioned last
night have nothing to do with border
security nothing
even border democrats like mark kelly
they're like i didn't hear anything
about the
the border there that actually makes any
sense okay and then
joe biden came to his long-awaited
conclusion this sucker went on for an
hour and a half and it was like
listening to an old story from your
grandparents and they're starting to
doze off and you're starting to doze off
and everybody's starting to doze off and
ted cruz is starting to doze off
literally okay so he he concludes with
this he suggests
something so absurd and dystopian
that it sort of beggars the imagination
he says that the insurrection was an
existential crisis
for the democracy and then he says
something about government and america
that is just
fundamentally untrue the
insurrection was an existential crisis a
test
on whether our democracy could survive
and it did
but the struggle is far from over the
question of whether our democracy
will long endure is both ancient and
urgent
as old as our republic
vital today our constitution opens with
the words as trade as it sounds
we the people was time remember that we
the people
are the government you and i
not some force in a distant capital not
some powerful force that we have no
control over
it's us it's we the people this is a
fundamental lie
the government is not us the government
is a group of people elected by us to
check and balance each other
and participate in limited enumerated
powers to protect our individual rights
i am not the government you are not the
government the government is not me
the government is my agent and the
government is supposed to have checks
and balances to prevent it from becoming
simple mob rule when he says the
government is us what he means is there
should be no obstacles to my
utopian and bizarre agenda that's what
he means he means no checks and balances
because after all why are we about
government government's you
he means that joe biden is me i'm joe
biden and joe biden is me and therefore
we have a complete confluence of
interest because i don't oppose me
he's a damned liar the fundamental basis
of the constitution of the united states
is that the government is not us which
is why we should worry about what the
government does which is why there
should be enumerated powers which is why
checks and balances
do matter it's why we have federalism
it's why we have
all of these systems that are designed
to prevent the government from invading
individual rights
the government is not us because we are
individuals
but democrats hate individuals they like
the we collectively because the we
collectively allows them to ram down
whatever they damn well please on
individuals
this is joe biden's vision okay this is
radicalism
dressed up in the guise of an old man
wandering around a nursing home
that is joe biden's vision for the
country and he's gonna go
balls out for as long as he is president
of the united states on this thing and
he
he does not care i mean he is willing to
go all the way on this
so i know a lot of people out there like
joe biden's not threatening no he is
deeply threatening
he's deeply threatening specifically
because he plays at being
non-threatening
because he seems non-threatening but
he's actually read that speech that is
the single most radical
address to a joint session of congress
of my lifetime
he makes barack obama seem like a
he wants to spend more money than has
ever been created completely rewrite the
nature of the relationship between the
federal government and the individual
and he wants to say that he's doing it
in your name because the government is
you
the government is not you joe biden is
not me i don't want joe biden anywhere
near anything that belongs to me
including my individual rights because i
don't trust him with any of those things
and you should not either if you have a
bone of sanity in your body
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wear are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment